can I get a bit of chopin's for one day
I see the answer got off of the board is
17 and a half square centimeters
agreement yes okay thank you very much
now really important hands down really
important you remember not just to be
good at actually doing the computation
like sometimes 515 we want to know why
why is it that you take these numbers
you multiple why don't you add them for
instance why don't you add those legs
why do we multiply them anyone remember
Frank movies on the textbook because
it's from the textbook so that leads me
to my next question which is why does
the textbook say that why pens out here
for a second because this is a vitally
important question even those of you in
fact maybe especially those of you got
this right I want to know why it's right
Molly don't suggest it's more of a
spatial type thing you can't get a space
by adding two legs oh yeah that's why
it's x squared ok yeah good the question
is about area right think all the way
back to when we started measurement and
I said to you length is about one
dimension right back and forth and area
is not about one dimension it's about to
write so that's why you need a dimension
gone this way times a dimension going
that way no matter how many lakes you
add together you still just get I've got
a wave which is what we're going to get
to over here yeah so that's what I
multiply you divide by two though what
was that about what's the division
coming yeah yeah it's half of the top of
what what is it hot all well it could be
a square yeah thank you i think jared i
have there it's a bit ly over sorry you
got idea it's half of a rectangle right
you can see in fact i've divided up
these two Pines insane these two cars
are the same that's why it's tough
question
4-sided shape no not for any 4-sided
shape so for example if you recall a
trapezium right that's not presume now
just you please you what makes it your
PC mature p.m. again what is it yeah
good there's that pair of parallel lives
there now the area of a trapezium is not
just multiplied together like a length
and width because there is no length or
width they're all they're all different
okay so it's a rectangle not just anyone
okay that looks good if you can't quite
read this it says 30 square centimeters
of agreement hair done okay wonderful
lots of hands thank you I this one here
this question has all the pull of red
herring unit bit of a force quit you've
got three numbers but clearly you don't
need or three numbers right so actually
what this question is doing is not just
working out can you can you workout area
but can you work out which is important
which details are important and which
ones art um this 13 doesn't get used in
the kills working over here why not why
is it irrelevant yeah why don't we need
it that's true why don't we need that
one does it so are you know five and 12
or the good sides but I'm going to push
on that question again why is it five
and 12 and not for instance five and 13
or 12 and 13 why did you choose those no
generically you can't have three things
two times to get it two dimensional area
okay good so this is the same idea we
look that before if you go this time
this times this like that's three links
that might be a ball you also like that
this is a 2d shape okay that's good yeah
anyways that's kind of like from that
point that one okay if I wanted to use
the 13 suppose I didn't have these guys
just suppose
and I've got this how I can still work
out the area if I know something else
what would I need to pair this with in
order to get its area anyway we don't
need da giris consign remember for me uh
this year right sometimes hi papa too
what's the actual formula that this is a
representation of what's the for you
with letters and stuff a data area
equals hello base times height on two
very good right so if i'm calling 13 the
base and to be a wee because it looks
like it's on the top and just turn your
hip right just make that the base
where's the hyphen of it yeah from here
it's gonna go inverted commas it's gonna
go up up to the top that's the top down
right if this is the base then that's
the top do you agree like you turn you
can see that or if you've got it in your
book you can just turn your book and you
don't have to give you something neck
ache alright so if that was the base
then this would be I don't know what
that is and that's why I don't use the
13 it's not useful to me okay that's 15
at all right last one 44 thumbs up
thumbs up yep wonderful again there's a
bit of a sneaky if you've made that 10
there is irrelevant again my question is
why why is that 10 Arella someone who
hasn't said anything yet Thomas okay
we're doing perimeter right and
perimeter literally means you measure so
you want to remember what Perry needs
like a periscope helps you see around
something so perimeter is the leg around
and it ends in the middle